heures en moyenne depuis
quelques années. Davidiens
taller nous explique.
- Aujourd'hui encore, l'urgence
de Charles-Lemoynees-Lemoynees-.
Après cinq heures d'attente,
Claudette Loiselle quitteson fik
n'aie été traité pour une plaie
qui s'est infectée.
CLAUDETTE LOISELLE
- Il est classé paarrivée ici v-
9 h 35, puis là, il est 2 h et
je n'en peux plus. Je m'en vais.
- Elle est ici parce que
de médecin de famille.
- Il n'y a plus de médecin, ça
fait 3-4 ans. Puis, les médecinn
médecin a pris sa retraite.
- C'est une des principales
sources de l'engorgements'accene
depuis quatre ans.
La durée moyenne de séjour
ambulatoire a légèrementde 4 hes
10 minutes à 4 heures 28 minutes
entre 2018 et 2022.
Mais po
sur civière, la dégradation
est plus marquée.
de séjour était de 13 heures
42 minutes. Au début de la
pandémie, l'attente sur civia m.
Et en ce printempse
atteint 16 heures 45 minutes.
ANDRÉ FORTIN,député PLQ, Pontiac
- Le gouvernement
l'exemple... l'excuse
de la pandémie aujourd'hui
d'attente aux urgences.
vernement cherche
des solutions à ce problème
chronique.
premier ministre du Québec- La i
vont à l'urgence devraient pas
être à l'urgence. Elles aun pre,
dans une clinique privée
ou un CLSC.
- Mais pour les patients sur
civière, c'est souvent le m
ailleurs dans l'hôpitalqui les .
Dre JUDY MORRIS, prés., Asso.
des médecins d'urgence du Qué te
cette situation-là, a exposéce s
rapidement. Quand les patients
arrivent, quand iloù aller,
bien, cette pression-là,
elle est mise essentiellement
sur les urgences.
- Pour lils Mark, on ne voit pas
vraiment de solution
à court terme.
- Bien, je suis frustrée.
Je suis porte les solutions
mises de l'avant pour tenter
de décongestionner les urgences,
il faudra tout d'abord
de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
qui frappe tous les maillons
du réseau de la santé.
Radio-Canada, Lon